un sol nu des collines arides et des
roches dépouillé
de loin en loin une oasis
partout une chaleur implacable le désert
du maghreb
en apparence une sorte de néant ou le
biologique n'a pas sa place
pourtant qu'elle soit de saab ou de
pierrailles ces étendues désertiques
sont peuplés de petites créatures
le désert est une mosaïque de biotope
différent chaque espèce a choisi celui
qui lui convient le mieux
sable pour les fournisseurs
rocher pour ceux qui peuvent se glisser
dans les petits interstices
les rares arbustes et on le domaine des
animaux et les et des grimpeurs
donc
beaucoup
au fil de l'évolution
insectes et mammifères coléoptères et
sauriens se sont adaptés chacun à sa
façon à l'aridité
et dans des conditions extrêmes la
concurrence est encore plus rude
qu'ailleurs
bien souvent la survie d un suppose la
mort des autres
15 heures
60 degrés au soleil
un scorpion noir à grosses que part en
chasse
le scorpion fait partie de la famille
des araignées et comme ses cousines il
est assez myope
en revanche il assure les pinces des
organes sensoriels très sensible
de l'ong se voit qu'ils réagissent au
moindre déplacement d'air
seulement c'est récepteur d'ondés de
vibration ne leur enseigne pas
précisément sur l'identité de celui qui
passe à proximité
ils peuvent aussi bien le conduire à une
proie qu'à un adversaire comme le 5
ce curieux sauriens et le spécialiste
des scorpions
il n'hésite pas à s'attaquer aux plus
dangereux d'entre eux celui ci justement
doté d'un venin mortel
il suffit de savoir le prendre
le scorpion a compris que cette
confrontation était à son désavantage
et le 5 qui a raté son attaque préfère
ne pas insister
on pourrait croire que c'est plein
desséché ne voit jamais la moindre
goutte d'eau
or il arrive trois ou quatre fois par an
que des pluies violentes sabbath quelque
part dans les montagnes provoquant
d'énormes creux et
les oueds se remplissent alors d'une
rougis par la terre qu'ils arrachent sur
leur passage les petites marques on
trouve parfois dans le nord du sahara
sont les résidus de ces crues soudaines
certaines d'entre elles sont quasi
permanente fort heureusement pour les
animaux incapable de vivre sans eau par
exemple ces tortues qui porte un bien
vilain non
lésés mid l'épreuve
temporaire ou permanente c'est marc
attire bien entendu toute la faune des
alentours
sont approchés c'est à la fois tenté sa
chance de trouver des proies et courir
le risque d'y faire de fatal rencontre
aucune inimitié entre la tortue et le
caméléon
simplement la méfiance de celui qui
croit à un inconnu
mis à part les espèces aquatiques comme
les tortues presque tous les animaux du
désert se contente de la soul au contenu
dans leur nourriture
c'est le cas du scorpion
mais si l'occasion se présente il se
désaltère volontiers
de plus le scorpion c'est bien qu'il
trouvera ici quantité d'insectes à
manger le caméléon aussi même s'il
préfère chasser dans les arbustes
du rayon criquets mouche le caméléon à
un régime assez diversifiée
et pourquoi ne pas goûter à cette
bestiole qui ressemble à s'y méprendre à
une énorme araignée
chasseurs novices ce jeune caméléon ne
se doute pas de ce qu'ils risquent en
attaque en un scorpion noir
une première morsure veut lui a cassé la
patte pendant quelques minutes
non content d'avoir damé le pion à son
agresseur le scorpion revient à la
charge
il n'y a qu'un moyen de neutraliser un
scorpion
sectionné immédiatement son aiguillon
venimeux
à défaut d'une telle précaution on
s'expose à une ou plusieurs injections
mortelles car le venin du scorpion
contient des toxines violente qui
paralyse très vite le système nerveux
le scorpion a réussi à piquer dans le
seul endroit tendre du caméléon la
paupière
mais il finira étouffé par cette
mâchoire qui ne peut plus lâcher prise
intrigué par la scène un autre caméléon
s'approche
pour s'apercevoir que son congénère est
déjà presque mort
si le caméléon est le plus nonchalants
des habitants du désert le plus vif et
sans doute celui ci l'a scolopendre
je
elle n'a de cesse d'inspecter les
infractuosités rocheuses pour y trouver
ces petits insectes préféré
sa démarche nerveuse provoque des
vibrations qui à dire d'un manque
ablement l'attention des scorpions en
maraude
pour tromper l'ennemi las colo pondre
possède en avant de la bouche une pince
venimeuse et on dise de qu un appendice
identique si bien qu'on ne suis jamais
par quel bout la prendre
le scorpion saisi la victime avec ses
pinces
soucieux d'économiser son précieux venin
il ne pique de son aiguillon que si
elles sont trop remuante
avec la scolopendre il n'y a pas à
l'idée
je
dotée elle aussi deux crochets venimeux
la scolopendre pic le scorpion au niveau
des articulations entre deux segments de
cuticules
celui ci essaie de lui faire lâcher
prise à l'aide de son éperon
le scorpion s'est immobilisé en
attendant que son venin agissent
rien ne saurait le trouble et dans ce
moment crucial
sauf ceux passant maladroit qui va
remuer le couteau dans la plaie
oui
fermement maintenu par une dépense du
scorpion la scolopendre n'a plus guère
de chance de s'en sortir entière
sa victime presque morte il l'emmène
dans une cachette ombragé pour la
dévorer en paix
pendant ce temps le caméléon poursuit
son chemin non sans mal
c'est pape ne sont décidément pas fait
pour la marche avec leur pouce opposable
elles sont exclusivement adaptées à l
escalade dans les arbres
si bien qu'il lui arrive par réflexe
d'attraper ses propres jambes les
prenant pour des branches
nouveau renoncer à l'ascension de ce
rocher et gagner un refuge plus familier
le scorpion n'a pas eu assez fin pour
dévorer entièrement la scolopendre il en
a laissé la moitié
belle aubaine pour des fourmis
carnivores que ces quelques centimètres
de chair fraîche encore un hymne et
d'impulsion nerveuse
contournez valide et muni d'une aussi
solide armure que le gast r doit-on se
méfier d'une poignée de fourmies
fusse-t-elle carnivores
peut-être
le gaster a beau avoir pour surnom le
dragon du désert il s'empresse de
déguerpir
le gaster préfère mettre un mur entre
ces fourmis vorace et lui
le gas terre est un cousin du grillon
avec sa cuirasse il peut escalader sans
crainte les plantes épineuses qui
s'épanouissent dans le désert
généralement il est certain que nul ne
viendra n'importune héricy
mais aujourd'hui ce n'est pas son jour
de chance
il se trouve que cette plante est
habitée par des fourmis qui vont le
traité naturellement comme un intrus
les fourmis ont trouvé son talon
d'achille
les articulations de ses pattes
comme il a besoin de toutes celles ci
pour se maintenir en équilibre il suffit
de le mordre tour à tour à toutes les
jointures pour l'obliger à décamper
on a surnommé le gaster d'aragon du
désert à cause des éperons qu'il a sur
le dos
en réalité il n'a rien de féroce
ils se contentent pour nourriture de ce
qu'ils trouvent en chemin souvent des
animaux morts mais aussi des graines et
des fruits en putréfaction
c'est un peu l'éboueur du désert
une centaine de minuscules attaquants au
monde il a serré contre ce géant sans
défense l'issue de la confrontation ne
fait pas de doute le dragon sera forcé
de battre en retraite
non
vous
il
le voici revenu sur son promontoire où
il pourra peut-être panser ses plaies
tranquillement
en début d'après midi la chaleur est
implacable
la température au sol et de 65 à 70
degrés tout le monde se terre dans
quelques coins d'ombré sauf le 5
toujours à l'affût d'une proie
ce scorpion jaune ferait bien son
affaire cette fois le 5 6 et pris
exactement comme il faut il a tout de
suite coupé la queue du scorpion unis de
l'aiguillon venimeux il le tient
désormais à sa merci
il
l'accès du désert est interdit a
beaucoup de végétaux seul qui vivent ce
qu'ils possèdent des dispositifs
spéciaux pour endurer la sécheresse
quelques graminées des épineux des
plantes grasses
quand on se penche sur ces plantes on
peut surprendre toutes les scènes du
théâtre de la vie de l'amour le plus
tendre à la guerre la plus cruelle
7 et perd argenté a tissé une
gigantesque toile presque invisible
malheur à celui qui ne devienne pas le
piège
le caméléon lui n'a pas besoin de tendre
des pièges pour la chasse son atout
numéro 1 et sa lenteur
on se déplaçant sans aucun mouvement
brusque il évite d'alerter ses proies
atout numéro deux c'est dieu qui pivote
en tous sens et indépendamment l'un de
l'autre aussi performant que des
périscopes
ajoutons à cela une langue extensible et
enduite d'une sorte de glu qui ne laisse
aux insectes aucune chance de s'échapper
ce
c
le caméléon est rompu
pourtant il va causer la perte de ce
coléoptère
une clique re
elle aurait pu retomber sur ses pattes
et s'envoler mais le destin a décidé de
livrer en pâture à des fourmis rousses
particulièrement agressive
première précaution lui briser les ailes
l'acs litres qui se nourrit le cadavre
et d'excréments dégage une odeur
nauséabonde
mais qu'importe c'est une belle proie et
elle pourrait faire des envieux il est
donc décidé de la mettre en sûreté dans
la fourmilière
une équipe est déjà en place pour
dégager l'entrée
ces fourmis rousses à abdomen noir
appartiennent à un ordre primitif qui
restait insectivores alors que les
fourmis plus évolués et vivent ailleurs
que dans le désert sont devenus omnivore
ou végétarienne
toutes les fourmis sont capables de
déplacer des poids considérable et c'est
bien connu leur dévouement à la
communauté est exemplaire
est ce une raison pour faire tant de
zèle
l'entrée de la fourmilière a été bien
dégagé mais elle reste un peu juste
tandis que le plus gros de l'équipe
soulève la clique un ou deux individus
creuse son zèle pour essayer d'agrandir
encore le passage
amenée par un coup de vent ou un coup du
sort cet autre clip est illico attaqué
par les fourmis
elle comprend vite qu'elle n'a pas
intérêt à s'attarder sur ce terrain
s'il s'avère impossible donc fournée
lacroix dans la fourmilière il faudra la
dépecer à l'extérieur et lang rongé par
petits morceaux
les fourmis ne sont plus un effort près
voilà près d'une heure et demie qu'elle
se démène avec ce butin
on trouve dans le dévers de nombreuses
espèces de fourmis insectivores
elles ont toujours à peu près le même
type de comportement
relativement calme lorsqu'elle s'occupe
du couvain au sein de la fourmilière
elle entre subitement en hyper activité
quand il s'agit de changer les nymphes
de place ou de partir en chasse
bien souvent la découverte d'une proie
inhabituelle les plonge dans un état
d'excitation extrême
surtout qu'on l'a dit pour moi est
intransportable
les combats entre individus d'une même
espèce sont fréquents et ont presque
toujours la même cause
les fourmis porte sur elle un coup
d'oeil factice une odeur émises par leur
reine dont elle s'enduisent les antennes
et ce code est différent pour chaque
tribu
6-2 fournis se rencontrent et s'aperçoit
qu'elles sont ennemis c'est
l'affrontement
ces deux individus appartiennent à une
variété de fourmi géante singulièrement
agressive capable de se battre jusqu'à
ce que mort s'ensuive
lorsqu une fourmi a perdu une antenne
elle n'a plus aucun sens de
l'orientation
ce qui tôt ou tard lui sera fatal
de son côté la fourmi victorieuse est
indemne il ne lui reste plus qu'à y
passer les soudures de ce duel dans la
poussière
si les fourmis hagist habituellement en
groupe ils leur arrivent dirait ton de
prendre des initiatives personnelles
qu'elles s'efforcent d'assumer jusqu'au
bout
celle ci a trouvé un magnifique but 1 le
cadavre d'un coléoptère une pie melli
qu'elle voudrait bien rapporter à sa
tribu
voici les images qui évoquent le plus
souvent le mot désert l'erg les dunes de
sable infinie et apparemment hostile à
toute forme de vie
pourtant même ici quelques petits
animaux parviennent à survivre en restes
enterrés sous le sable aux heures les
plus chaudes
ainsi le poisson des sables avec son
museau aplati qui lui permet de creuser
la gale et hod appartient à la famille
des soli fusent ceux qui fuient le
soleil
avec ses longues pattes fines elle court
trois fois plus vite que son cousin le
scorpion
avec les crocs shekels en avant de la
tête elle impressionne à juste raison
presque tous ses voisins
ces deux crochets qu'on appelle des
kelly sert lui servent aussi bien à
injecter son venin pour tuer ses
victimes qu'à creuser les terriers
ses pattes sont héritiers de long pour l
sensorielle qui capte les vibrations
trahissant le passage d'une proie ou la
proche d'un danger
ce jeune cobra est lui aussi à la
recherche d'un trou bien ombragé
incapable de creuser lui-même un terrier
le cobra s'installe couramment dans un
refuge tout fait
mais la gale et on n'hésitera pas à
pincer l'intrus pour le dissuader
d'insister
encore quelques minutes et la gale et
odorat fini d'aménager son terrier
postés à l'entrée elle pourra gaieté ses
proies favorites
coléoptères
termites et arachnides de toutes sortes
ou encore d'observer les allées et
venues d'un animal qui rivalisent de
vitesse avec elle la petite chez reboise
un des rares mammifères vivant dans les
dunes la gerbe rey se sert de ses pattes
avant et de ses dents pour creuser des
terriers qui descendent en spirale
jusqu'à un mètre vingt de profondeur on
voit bien à quoi lui servent ses longues
pattes arrière
hélas sa course bondissante peut être
interrompue à tout moment par le fennec
son ennemi de toujours
le hérisson du désert creuse lui aussi
des tanières où il passe le plus clair
de ses journées
sauf quand il n'a pas trouvé de 3
pendant ces chasse nocturne il peut
parcourir alors des distances étonnante
pour se procurer de la nourriture
un grand marcheur est un insatiable
dévoreur d'insectes
papillon critiqué scarabées et pinelli
n'ont pas intérêt à croiser son chemin
le hérisson du aussi des serpents des
galets aude et des scorpions si l'on
passe à sa portée
la plus rude épreuve pour tous ces
animaux la tempête de sable
insectes mammifères et reptiles sont
tous égaux devant les caprices du vent
et tous omnubilé par le même impératif
se mettre à l'abri
ce petit lézard gecko est tellement
léger qu'une rafale le renverse comme un
rien et le laisse bien en peine de se
retourner
l'eau qui dont le désert est synonyme de
vie peut être aussi porteuse de mort
les bergers nomades et leurs troupeaux
mais également les animaux sauvages qui
ont accès à l'eau des puits et risquent
leur vie aussi désaltérant
cette eau est pourtant potable et ne
contient aucune substance toxique
seulement elle est habitée par des
sangsues
les chèvres ont appris à se méfier des
sangsues et font attention de ne pas en
aspirer en buvant
mais le donc j'ai bien de leurs larves
minuscule invisible
si un animal en aval une elle s'installe
sous la langue ou dans son estomac
grossit et finit par le faire mourir
les cactus du désert du maghreb sont en
fait des plantes importées du mexique
qui se sont très bien adaptés à ce
milieu
on les appelle des plantes succulentes
parce qu'elle accumule de l'eau dans
leurs tissus
chacune d'elle est une oasis pour le
peuple des insectes
on y rencontre les plus communs et aussi
les plus étranges
cette brindille bizarroïde est un cric
est aussi doué pour le mimétisme que les
fameuses insectes branche les phasmes
le cours des criques et est recouvert
d'un tégument perméable qui leur permet
de transpirer et de se refroidir par
évaporation
ainsi ils peuvent sans danger et
s'exposer en plein soleil même aux
heures les plus chaudes à condition de
restaurer souvent leurs réserves d'eau
et comme ils ne boivent pas ils doivent
donc manger quotidiennement la moitié de
leur poids en végétaux est donc passé de
longues heures sur leur plant préférées
le déguisement du criquet et
s'améliorera me contre d'éventuels
ennemis c'est pourquoi il reste
absolument immobile dans la journée
sauf cas de force majeure celui ci s'est
pris dans une 3d d'araignée et voudrait
bien essayé de se dégager
ce
revoilà notre dragon du désert qui se
lancent dans une épreuve d' escalade
exercice dans lequel il excelle
d'ailleurs grâce à ses pattes qui
saisissent les pigments des cactus comme
les barreaux d'une échelle
si le gas terre et le cric et n'ont
aucune raison de se craindre leur
rencontre les saisies
oui
ce
contre toute attente le dragon sera la
planche de salut du clic et il va lui
servir de tremplin pour s'envoler
un jour viendra où notre dragon du
désert pourra lui aussi s'envoler il est
encore à l'état larvaire est dépourvu
d'elle mais celle-ci se développeront
lors de sa prochaine venue
ces coléoptères très nombreux dans le
désert sont les bousiers qui pondent
leurs oeufs dans des boulettes
d'excréments
à l'époque de la reproduction ils
remplissent leurs terriers de crocs
devant tous genres mais cette agitation
attire les cinq revendre aux alentours
notre
celui ci les jeunes s'ils avaient un peu
plus d'expérience il saurait qu'il ne
faut pas s'en prendre aux bousier la
substance amer qu'ils sécrètent les
rondins mangeable
à quelques pas de là un crapaud de
mauritanie au lieu de rejoindre le
terrier où ils passent la journée s'est
laissé engourdir par la chaleur
le 5 va connaître avec lui la même
déception qu'avec les bouviers
la famille est exaspéré peut-être par
son précédent échec le 5 ne trouve rien
de mieux à faire que de se jeter sur ce
crapaud qui n'est pas une de ses proies
habituelles
c'était en vérité ce qu'il pouvait faire
de pire
le crapaud de mauritanie produit 1
l'équipe toxiques encore plus infects
que celui des bouviers
ce
notre point d'eau de tout à l'heure
semble totalement asséchée
ce qui serait catastrophique pour cette
tortue lépreuse
il arrive que les oueds qui se
remplissent à l'occasion d'une chute
d'eau soudaine ne s'assèche pas
complètement égard de ça et là dans leur
lit des trous d'eau qu'on appelle des
guelta
certaines de ces guelta donc un sursis à
ses cours et finissent par disparaître
d'autres constituent des citernes
permanente alimenté par des sources
s'écoulant en profondeur des montagnes
jusqu'aux plaines
et c'est ainsi que le désert vous
réserve parfois de bonnes surprises
plus étonnant encore cette minuscule
flac et peuplé de poissons
les tilapias ou des silures capable en
cas de sécheresse de survivre dans la
boue humide et d'attendre des jours
meilleurs
aux abords de ces réservoirs d'eau il
n'est plus question de défendre un
territoire ces plages de vienne par la
force des choses domaine public
elles sont le théâtre de nombreuses
rencontres qui suscite selon les acteurs
méfiance hostilités ou indifférence
totale
il est assez rare qu'un caméléon
s'aventure à terre donc peut-être la
surprise du crapaud
n'étant agressif ni l'un ni l'autre ils
préfèrent passer leur chemin sans faire
d'histoire
notre 5 n'a toujours pas assouvir sa
faim
ce promeneur pourrait bien faire les
frais de sa voracité
attaque parfaitement réussi le scorpion
est maîtrisé
le 5 n'a plus qu'à raffermir sa prise
pour lui trancher la queue
mais cette fois la manoeuvre n'est pas
aussi aisé qu'avec le scorpion jaune de
l'autre jour
le scorpion à grosses que est beaucoup
plus vigoureux
le lâcher ne serait ce qu'un dixième de
seconde pour mieux le saisir serait
risqué la morsure fatale
vous
où
et
on
s'il n'a pas réussi à couper l'aiguillon
venimeux le 5 a suffisamment malmené le
scorpion pour le mettre hors d'état de
nuire
il va pouvoir la vallée comme il se doit
la tête la première
la voracité des cinq est devenue
légendaire
certains bergers nomades du sahara
prétendent qu'il s'approcherait la nuit
de leur campement pour téter le lait des
chèvres coucher
on les trouverait au petit matin en
revue endormi au milieu des troupeaux
tu
encore des fourmis rousses en plein
travail
un travail de construction de grande
envergure apparemment mais le chantier
est en souterrain on ne saura pas plus
ce scorpion jaune un but us d'occident
n'a pas choisi le meilleur endroit pour
chercher un abri
il a trouvé une belle cavernes bien
fraîche mais hélas déjà investi par des
fourmis
double
son éperon venimeux ne peut rien face à
des attaquants aussi minuscule les
fourmis par contre le mode si méchamment
aux articulations qu'il préfère s'enfuir
deuxième erreur cette fois il a mis en
alerte les sentinelles de la fourmilière
ces fourmis rousses abdomen noirs sont
finalement plus redoutable que n'importe
quel autre prédateur
l attaque avec leurs mandibules et
injecte dans les plaies une sécrétion
corrosive à base d'acide formique
la victime une fois rongé par les
brûlures n'offre plus aucune résistance
le scorpion pratiquement paralysé est
devenue en quelques minutes une victime
impuissante
les fourmis sont incontestablement les
rênes du désert
elle forme les populations des plus
nombreuses et sont représentés partout
dans les cailloux dans le sable dans les
règles dans les oasis elle symbolise
l'extraordinaire adaptabilité des
petites créatures au milieu désertique
les poissons des sables les gerboise
légal et hod excelle dans l'art de se
réfugier sous le sable c'est dans la
dimension qu'il faut chercher la raison
pour laquelle tous ces petits animaux
parviennent à survivre ici
qui dit petite taille qui tout d'abord
plus de facilités pour s'abriter du
soleil
d'autre part plus on est petit - on a
besoin d'eau les coléoptères les
scorpions les fourmis sont recouverts
d'une sorte de cire extrêmement
résistantes à la chaleur qui les empêche
de transpirer
les fourmis possèdent tous ces avantages
plus la force du nombre si bien qu'un de
scorpions l'une des espèces les plus
dangereuses de ce milieu peut mourir
sous les attaques d'une foule
d'individus mille fois plus petit que
lui
subissant ainsi l'une des mystérieuses
lois qui régissent la vie dans le désert